how old are you when you first joined
the gang and how did you get into it so
I was 12 years old when I first joined
and then three months into it I caught
my case how I got in is they called it a
put on you know you get beat up by like
however many people from there you got
to put in work did you like examine the
benefits of each group oh okay this is
like four years yeah it's just like they
got Asian boys has good dental
how I got put on was they hit me up I
was walking on the street little kid
yeah are you banging on me and I was
like no you know I didn't know it was
like a gang of them they pulled the
strap and then one of the dudes and
sitting shoddy was like you want to kick
it and I was like hell yeah so they let
me in the car and then I started going
around with them but it wasn't no
sampling no pamphlets here you should
have an older brother or any older
cousins in the same game yeah I have an
older brother in the same game wasn't
your brother that hit you up
follow me